hello folks welcome to rational science
hey guys today I was gonna postpone the
lecture I'm not feeling very well I
caught a cold
so I got sore throat I've got my stuffy
nose put some drops just a couple
minutes ago uh see if at least I can get
the passages open in there took an
aspirin see if that helps anyways the
reason I didn't postpone the class is
subject matter today is weight
and I absolutely love that subject very
close to my heart okay and so I'll wait
that you like so much
we'll we'll find out well because it's a
big Source Thumb in special relativity
that's what it comes down to and we'll
see that today anyways let's get started
here uh we're gonna go with uh our
Extinction phase and a fellow had some
nasty comments to make so let me go with
this first okay no
see me you can read that and keep
peddling politics Bill despite being a
failed communist hello you never
understood how the world works that's
why you keep peddling politics instead
of understanding the reality of what is
actually going on in the world and what
is driving it behind the scenes so
please do us all of do us all a favor
and stop your BS opinions on how the
world Works whether we went to the moon
or not whether viruses exist or not and
their electron electron micrograph
interpretations whether viruses exist
yeah uh so uh that's the next level
conspiracy theory well yeah um
the first thing I want to mention on
that you know we talk we don't do
politics and here's a rundown of that
okay what we try to do here is
extinction and politics
only in relation to Extinction how did
you touch on politics yeah but it's not
really politics because uh I don't give
recommendations on who to vote for well
it's not religion but you do it is a
religion but you do go into the
political realm what do I what I mean is
you don't give recommendations but you
do give your two cents on things that
are happening in Russia or some in
relation to in other words I I try to
put it as much as possible in the
context of Extinction how does that you
know get us closer to Extinction or
farther away from Extinction that's the
only real uh context in which I raise
these issues here's a rundown you know
politics opinions and recommendations
essentially I don't do that I don't tell
you who to vote for you don't do that
and uh what is good what is bad I don't
you know a long time ago I left that
behind Okay so I don't do politics in
that sense I think politics is what you
see there religion okay and and I look
at the news only in relation to
Extinction you know I've also done it
without relation to Extinction well in
general just for fun you'll go in 10
minutes or whatever yeah but in general
the the focus is extinction that's
that's the context in which I try to put
it okay uh but this fellow apparently
you know has this idea that everything
is a hoax a lot of flat earthers are
like that they think everything's a hoax
and so they don't believe in anything
and
and I'm not saying that there are not uh
false Flags out there there are okay
there's a lot of misinformation
given by the governments themselves not
one but all of them okay they have to do
politics so they have to keep the flocks
in line so there's a lot of that going
on so I don't deny that but not
everything is a hoax going to the moon
this guy mentioned viruses and all this
other stuff
um
so what I want to say here is that this
uh just criticized he said bill you
don't know how the world works fine okay
great I tell you how I think the world
works I get my own conclusions and of
course I could be wrong right but the
question is he didn't tell us what he
believes he's saying I don't understand
how the world Works implying that he
does
and the question is if he does please
tell us how you do or uh think the world
yeah or or is it that you're afraid to
be laughed at
you know I mean the guy might go in
there and say well you know the World is
Flat and everybody would laugh at him so
he says I'm not going to tell you how
how the world is how it works I'm just
going to say that you're wrong I mean
it's too late I'm already laughing at on
the fact that he he thinks viruses don't
exist well I don't know I mean he
mentioned that as an example he
mentioned uh that's a weird that's a
really specific example you only say
that example if you think viruses don't
exist well yeah and there's a lot of
people that don't believe in uh that
viruses and bacteria don't don't exist
yeah they don't accept that they have a
different version they say uh you know
you get sick uh perhaps because uh
you're not finding the natural way of
living you know Etc well then here's the
question is because we're talking about
viruses we can't see them I'm talking
about Flat Earth we can't see that we're
talking about uh the armies and politics
things that are outside of our periphery
is everything that is outside of things
we can see just doomed to become
misinterpreted by by groups of people
yeah but then you have situations like
you say we can't see Flat Earth okay we
have sent
no but listen we sent probes out there
that taken pictures of the Earth from
afar it shows a roundish earth okay a
spherical object out there
[Laughter]
flat yeah but but the issue is uh and
these people simply deny that we went
into space so they they constantly
outflank you they say well we haven't
gone out into space a lot of people out
there don't even believe there are
satellites but that's what you know and
and so or that we have never sent
satellite I heard some people say that
you know our communication out there uh
you know the uh your internet internet
all this stuff is done through wires
through you know through uh you're on
Earth so they outflanked you constantly
and okay you know they can take it as
far as they want they say everything's a
hoax the government is making you
believe that the Earth is round and
those pictures taken from afar was never
taken they they were made in Hollywood
or who knows where you know so you know
uh I mean you know you can take it as
far as you want all I can tell you is my
assumptions my set of assumptions and
I'm telling you how I think the world
works or is in relation to Extinction
this uh he wants to debate I mean I
don't even know why he reads his waste
this time writing if he's not going to
say look this is the way the world works
oh okay so now we all know what's going
through his mind he's not adding
anything yeah why do you even address it
but that's my point my point if if
you're going to talk about something at
least you know put something in there on
why you think the way you think and then
we can you know sink our teeth into it
but but I just throwing something out
there and then hiding yourself you know
that's cowards person it's boring
because he doesn't add it yeah he
doesn't add anything to the uh that in
silence are the same okay so what do we
do we do Extinction here and uh this is
uh these are the two things you know
that I always recommend extension 101
before Extinction 102. everybody's an
expert on human extinction whether it's
going to happen or not and how it's
going to happen but nobody seems to be
an expert on extinction 101 which is you
know how do Mass extension or background
extensions for that matter how did they
happen
see if you cannot rationalize a mass
extinction
you have nothing to say yet about human
extinction because you know nothing
about an Extinction you haven't shown us
that you're proficient in extinction and
what are the issues with Extinction 101
a specifically mass extinction well you
know
um first uh you got to do Extinction 101
before 102 which is the one at the
bottom right uh do you have a mechanism
of Extinction how Extinction happens
that's right every time yeah and I know
there I I put it you can't use an ad hoc
mechanism like saying well for this
species this is how it happened for this
other one this other thing happened this
other one yet another one you know this
one here was a volcano you could yeah
but it's it's messy yeah yeah it's uh it
gets into because rule yeah well some
people would argue that it's a matter of
time before some disaster wipes out a
species so it could be a different thing
every time yeah that's one issue but uh
what we're seeing is simultaneous sweet
you know like if a comet hit the Earth
right for example in days of the
dinosaurs okay how did the dinosaurs on
the other side of the planet die well
they say well those died because they
were you know there were these waves
that you know uh buried them you know
underneath the water or maybe there was
uh all this uh acid rain falling down on
them or the or you know or there was
this uh Cloud that covered the planet so
they have one uh mechanism for different
species right and how do the ones Under
the Sea die well the acidity of the
waters killed them and when they kill
the others well I killed these because
they had less tolerance and so they go
through through all these ad hoc uh
mechanism one for each species in one
Extinction that's a No-No that means you
don't have a slightest clue of how this
season happens yeah and so that's what
I'm referring to there now the other
issue here is you have to explain cell
activity how how does Mother Nature you
know select because you know the mammal
survived and some plants survive
specifically the angiosperms right what
died primarily or went away almost
entirely were the conifers right and so
plant certain plants died certain ones
survived certain animals died certain
ones survived the question is how do you
explain that that's selectivity okay and
specifically uh chronological
selectivity because you know what died
were the old species you know the
dinosaurs and the conifers were much
older than the mammals and the
angiosperm as a species you mean yeah
and then as an order right as a major
order you know category and then before
that we had the same situation for
example in the Permian and also in the
Triassic where the older plants the
older animals were the ones that died
and the new ones were the ones who
continued you'd have to explain that so
you're saying there are certain patterns
they keep repeating like Clues yeah that
people left uh I guess account for in
whatever explanation they come up with
and all I'm saying that's where I'm
going to come in with my questions you
know I'm going to come in and say well
explain this explain that you're saying
this is this wasn't a coincidence that
happened every time as such so this must
be linked to the explanation of the what
I call the cookie cutter you know we
apply the same cookie cutter in
different ages something is repeating
itself and we have to look at those uh
that pattern that cookie cutter and
figure out what is happening every time
we have a mass extinction in other words
at least that's where I'm going to ask
the questions so at least you know where
I'm coming from because I'm open on this
I'm telling you where I'm gonna hit you
people don't talk about extinctions much
no because they don't know they don't do
any research on extension they're all
into business or into it it's a really
interesting topic today it's an interest
topic but as far as I know common person
on the street thinks there was just one
Extinction the dinosaurs yeah I think I
think that's the the common knowledge is
there was only one Extinction the
dinosaurs after I hit them or Comet or
whatever some rock from the sky killed
them all and here we are ta-da yeah
that's that's I think that's why it's
not really looking because because the
knowledge out there is there was only
one so there's nothing to explain so
when that happened was an asteroid so
people know nothing about the trash at
the Jurassic the Permian the uh or
division who study that maybe but yeah
but that's what I'm saying people who
talk about human extinction first have
to know something about or demonstrate
Proficiency in extinction what do you
know about past Extinction can you
answer those if you can how do you
expect that you are an expert in human
except you don't have to be an expert
just as long as you understand yeah but
I mean you won't be able to understand
it if you don't understand extinctions
in general and the other issue again is
yeah you wanna you wanna show that you
know something about Extinction so that
unit can extrapolate whatever mechanism
you come up with to man and say this is
why man's gonna die
is that the same way as the dinosaurs or
the uh Permian uh you know synapsides or
whatever but with extra steps it's got
some extra [__] with humans because we
got economy and all that okay and then
then you can move on to Extinction um oh
then you also have to explain you know
how the animals uh air Land and Sea died
at the same time more or less but not
all it's the selectivity it's like
certain
I'm just gonna go on food chains
yeah that's what they are disappeared
but then you have here Extinction 102
now you've finished with Extinction 101
you showed your proficiency you know you
can explain that to some degree okay
then now we can continue right and um
until we move on to humans hey will
humans become extinct that's that's one
question you want to answer some people
say humans won't become extinct we will
go to the stars and then expand
throughout the Universe uh if anything
you can say you know they're gonna die I
guess with a big crunch you know we'll
live all the way to those days
uh and then so the question is you know
if yes when and by when I don't mean a
specific date I'm saying you know are we
going to die in 10 years in 100 years in
a thousand years in a million years and
there's a difference I mean if it's in a
million years we don't have to worry too
much but if it's going to happen in the
next 10 years I think we're all
concerned right so that kind of thing
you know put us more or less in the
ballpark of when you think
uh yeah humans are going to uh go
extinct I mean I think I think the
finitude of human history
that's a that's a really rare belief
most people just believe [__] goes on
and on or they don't think about it but
it's weird to think about the fact that
human history is linear and then it ends
the fact that
things don't repeat it's not that yeah
even even there even there even there
it's not linear for example population
is not linear the population has no
that's not what I mean no no but I'm I'm
just going on the trends you know uh the
fact that there are changes through
times means that history doesn't really
repeat it yeah that's what I was saying
okay in other words you have this long
curve where we have very little
population growth and then in the last
what is it 19th century officially you
know population exploded especially in
the advanced Nations who had the
children not the poor people the rich
people had to and and people can't
understand that today because they say
no poor people have people they have uh
children no no in the 19th century it
was the rich who had children it was the
advanced Nations where population
exploded not in Africa not in Asia in
the advanced Nations the United States
Europe those were the ones that expanded
rapidly anyway to China and India have
the biggest populations today because
they acquire that population later on in
other words they did have quite a bit of
population but their population was
growing very slowly relatively to the
relative to the Western World it was
growing slowly in the 19th century it
took off in the 20th century okay so uh
we need we need to understand the
Dynamics of population and people have
these uh
stereotypes that oh it's poor people who
have children absolutely not it's uh
people who are in the country that have
children people in the cities don't have
children whether poor or Rich yes okay
so we have to focus these things in the
right way or put them in the right
context or at least if you want to
debate them no problem but you know show
your hand
and then here we have you know you have
to come up with a guaranteed mechanism
of extension for man you cannot say for
example well but here you can say well
we've got a new car each other
okay you could say that you're saying
that's not a matter of time no no it's a
question of we might not nuke ourselves
what if we don't nuke ourselves then
does that mean we live forever in other
words nuking is not a gift mechanism the
mechanism should be something like that
I don't want to put words in anyone's
mouth but it should be like akin to
starvation because if you if you look at
a dog and you say if you don't feed that
dog he will eventually die yeah that's a
guarantee that's a guaranteed but if you
say a comment is going to kill us well
what if the comment doesn't come does
that mean we're not guaranteed can't
count on it yeah in other words those
are not valid mechanisms to say humans
are going to adopt because a comet or
because of nukes okay because those may
not happen that means you haven't
guaranteed the extinction you're saying
it should be something it has to be
something guaranteed and here you have
some valid ones for example uh just uh
as examples right runaway greenhouse you
can say in 100 million years or 200
million years eventually we might have
greenhouses because that that is a
process that might likely be developed
through the sun right uh you know
getting hotter Etc and so people might
say look that's when we're going to die
in 200 million years so at least you
have a theory that explains why humans
are going to die in 200 million years if
we don't get off the planet the other
one is there the sun Nova that might
have been five billion years and that
might be your your uh your theory you
might say look we won't die until uh
five billion years later why because
there's going to be a supernova and so
now you have a theory that is almost
guaranteed because if the sun blows up I
think we're all gone right so in that
sense that is a guaranteed or a more
believable
um mechanism but to say that we're going
to Nuke each other we might not say that
a comment is going to hit us or there's
going to be a supernova nearby well all
that might not happen so you haven't
guaranteed the extinction of Human
Rights so these are the questions that
uh you know that uh
um I'm going to be asking for people who
you know who claimed that they know
about Extinction I mean it's fun to
think about just armchair here let me
show you some uh excuses or some what
people believe out there are going to
cause the extension of man and none of
these are guaranteed okay and you can
see them here climate change number one
why because it's in everybody's mind
that's the only reason honestly well the
question is can you tell me how climate
is going to kill us what is the
mechanism in other words unless you can
you can justify how Climate Change is
Gonna you know we can't do anything
about it uh
you know like live underwater or go on
boats or I thought the theory was the
greenhouse greenhouse gas thing well the
Sun keeps getting more yeah and and we
might even in that case create uh some
chemical that uh counteracts that in the
air by that that's deterministic but
deterministic is climate change
that's a certain degree I guess but
again uh you can say climate change but
climate change is just a label we need
to find out you know what the mechanism
of Extinction is related to climate
change how does climate change create a
mechanism that extinguishes extinguishes
uh the human race that's the question
okay that's what you gotta reason for us
pretty sure people have done that well
good I'd like to hear it isn't that just
the standard yeah
know because people just say climate
change everything is melting and the
animals are done
polar bears have a little uh ice in
which to stand you know I mean that
doesn't tell me how humans became
extinct tell me how climate change does
kill us is it through the food chain is
it because we're going to have no water
everything's gonna heat up you know what
is the mechanism that you propose there
are there climate change can affect many
things yeah yeah you know and uh we can
also say hey there's going to be a just
like in the past uh we went through
heating Cycles we could go back to a
cooling cycle you know either one of
those could wipe us off yeah but but my
point is maybe it doesn't wipe us off
because as soon as it gets too hot maybe
the climate changes back to cold again
that's my point you know so I don't know
if it's guaranteed tell me the mechanism
asteroid may not happen if I over that
one I don't know uh virus you know
disease I don't know about that probably
not good old-fashioned War again War
hasn't killed anybody uh all of humanity
it has has killed a lot of people never
it's always a percentage same with
viruses by the way it never kills all of
a species it only kills certain
um percentage of the uh you know of the
species
and then AI revolved that one maybe that
one might be deterministic well you
could you could you could uh debate You
could argue that
eventually we'll develop AIS that are
just so good that we become Obsolete and
then they just kill us off so you think
we're gonna do that we're gonna allow
the AIS to be outside of our control
yeah
yeah it's a possibility I don't think so
I don't think we'll ever get there but
yeah you know uh Justified and that's
fine I have no problem I'm just saying
you need to justify that's all I'm
saying you have to come up with a
mechanism say this is the mechanism how
we're gonna die then then it's okay oh
we just don't we just don't die well
yeah that's also some people that one's
hard to explain though okay uh so um
this is what we propose uh mass
extinction we're saying that the
ecological pyramid is going to overturn
and uh background Extinction was the one
on the bottom says how one species
disappears and that is when it's uh
population pyramid overturns what does
population pyramid overturn involve
involves two things involves aging of
the population right uh the pyramid
overturns right and the loss of genetic
diversity those two things are
symptoms that a species is old we are an
old species now okay we've only been
around maybe 200 300 000 years but we
are older than the dinosaurs are because
uh our population pyramid has overturned
we have no chance of overturning it back
again uh it's overturned in since 1963
on a consistent basis you know we have
less and less we're producing less and
less people proportionally year by after
year and there's nothing we can do to
overturn that because we're moving from
the country to the city and that's what
creates that problem primarily but we're
going to die not because of that we're
going to die because of what I showed in
the top the overturning of the
ecological pyramid what's going to
happen according to no we're not too
many lions out there no we are the Lions
watch out for the Lions guys they're
gonna kill us all yeah no what happened
what's going to happen is
um uh our economics you know it's an
economic problem our economics is going
to run out uh we have no way of growing
forever economically speaking and at
some point we're going to reach a
plateau and from there it's gonna
overturn very quickly and what's going
to happen is suddenly more and more
people are out of work uh you won't be
able to create money from the magic wand
as we do today where you know
governments just create money and say
okay we solved the problem and let the
other uh Administration worry about the
how they're going to deal with that and
everybody does the same thing and at
some point you know the buck stops here
at some point you will not come
governments will not be able to do that
anymore they will not be able just to
create money out of nothing because all
you're doing is evaluating the coin and
the worker will not be able to make it
till the end of the month and companies
are not going to be able to sell to
those people who have no disposable
income Etc et cetera so it's a chain
that's all connected and the whole
system collapses when it collapses it
doesn't collapse slowly it collapses
vertically downwards okay well
especially because we try everything we
can until it collapses right
usually those things are good in the
short term bad in the long term where
we're taking for the future kind of
thing and all I'm saying is that's the
mechanism in general that I propose if
we can go in a lot of detail but not
today okay okay so what is related to
some of this we have uh big China
China's big on the news lately I mean
for months now and I think from here to
the end of time we're going to hear a
lot about China so if you hear me
talking about China you know why okay
and here's a couple uh headlines out
there the telegraph in England says
China must come clean on biggest
military buildup in peace time warns
James cleverly who is the foreign
secretary okay so what's the issue there
China is building its Army and its Navy
and this fellow complains to say why are
you doing that in peace time well the
Chinese would probably answer because
the United States are are putting this
uh fence around us you know it's like
they used to ask the um the Northerners
during the Civil War would ask the
southern uh Southerners say why why are
you fighting and the guy would say
because you know they were maybe in
South Carolina or maybe in Tennessee or
some says because you're here
that's why we're fighting in other words
they weren't fighting for the blacks for
uh freedom for the blacks they were
fighting because someone had invaded
their state which was their country you
know the way they saw it so you're here
that's why I'm fighting because you're
here and that's more or less what the
Chinese would answer here and say look
we're fighting because you're here you
know if the United States did not have
all these um ships out there in the
Pacific you know China probably would
not have to build up but it builds up
because the United States is there
that's one issue the United States is
there because it fears that China is
growing you know there's a mistrust on
both sides say oh you guys are creating
these islands these uh where you're
putting your military in the middle of
the ocean you're saying that this
Waterway belongs to you and that's why
we're here to make sure that you know
International traffic goes smoothly and
so they send the military ships out
there you know the naval ships and so
the other side says oh you sent your
naval ship so we're going to build more
naval ships and you have this arms build
up okay these this arm's raised so I
think that's the answer to that uh the
other known here from Bloomberg U.S
companies in China grow more pessimistic
about bilateral ties yeah what's
happening is you know a lot of
businesses are in China and they want to
make money and right now you know the
United States of course she is uh uh
putting a stop to a lot of Technology
transfer to China especially in the
world of chips where I used to work uh
summer inductors you know integrated
circuits they don't want China to get
the advanced chips and because of that
they're stopping a lot of Technology
transfer to companies Western companies
really in China and because of that
China says hey you're interrupting
international trade and because of that
we're going to take you know counter
measures and uh so there's again this
arms race in the business world as well
so we have two World arms races and
what's happening here and here's the map
okay we're having a split world we have
on the one hand Russia and China who see
uh uh convenience in in being together
today tomorrow they might be enemies
again like they were when they were both
Communists Soviet Union and China right
they were enemies at the time now
they're friends and it's just
friendships of convenience but yeah we
we have this world more or less divided
in two parts okay and so the question is
whether this can affect every single one
of us whether it's going to affect the
global economy which is what I'm saying
is going to eventually collapse and
create and uh lead to the extinction of
man okay so these are things to that I
at least consider going I'm looking at
politics okay so these are things that
are running through my head you know how
does this affect us uh meaning the
extinction of man how close does this
bring us to the extinction of man is
there a better way a more peaceful way
to extend or postpone the extinction of
man or is this bringing us closer to the
extreme
like you said it's not that it's
bringing it closers that this is a
inevitable consequence of this linear of
competition well not competition but the
whole process of the extinction of man
this is just one of the Milestones that
are inevitable in in the in The Road Not
that we're doing anything to make it
come closers there are certain things
that are just gonna happen on the way
there yeah but the question is is there
something we could do our politicians
our economists whoever out there you
know uh is there something anyone can do
out there that would help us uh postpone
extension like if if we could look at
the future and say oh we should have
done this in the past if we did it today
would we live longer would would we uh
postpone the day of Extinction the Day
of Reckoning you know what's one or two
things you would recommend
like what do you think Humanity could do
to postpone Extinction well let me let
me put uh something in there I think
Mother Nature wants competition okay
Mother Nature has put competition
everywhere you know you see it in the
animal world you see it among humans
there's competition and maybe the
solution to counteract with Mother
Nature instilled in us or put in there
would be to have Monopoly like you know
we all agree we're all friends right and
some people believe that actually
believe that the Chinese the American
the rulers right we're talking about Xi
Jinping and uh Putin and uh and uh Biden
that in secret behind the scenes they're
all really friends and they all actually
are colluding okay they're all in
agreement but they tell their people oh
the Americans oh the Chinese all the
Russians so that people say oh yeah we
got to fight them and Etc
yeah keep the illusion when there's
really no competition at the high level
some people actually believe that I
don't I don't make that assumptions I
think there is really competition okay
and
um and I think it's inevitable and
competition in this sense leads to
destruction because at the end when
there's only two empires
you know it's not like one beach the
other and it says okay now we can all
grow and live in peace no that's the end
of the world because part of that
process is going to be the collapse of
the economies and part of that process
is very likely going to be the exchange
of nukes
and I don't think we can recover from
that especially from the economic aspect
not So Much from the nukes nukes will
kill a lot of people but not everybody
but we'll collapse as the global economy
and I don't think you can restart that
again that's my take on that okay
okay so a couple more issues just uh
some news headlines that came out this
week yarn over takes dollar to become
most used currency in China across
border transactions for the first time
we have another coin out there that
um is replacing the dollar in some parts
of the world and it's not the only place
uh we have the bricks that is now used
also for uh oil transactions uh we have
talks between Argentina and Brazil for
some common currency that would help in
their cross border transactions so you
know people are talking a lot lately
about you know creating new coins that
will compete against the dollar uh will
that happen next year or so absolutely
not I don't think it will but uh it is
growing as the article said there you
know it's expanding and so the question
is what are the consequences of that for
the global economy it seems like a lot
of countries aren't satisfied with the
us being on top anymore well no part of
the issue also is that the United States
uses the dollar as a weapon that's the
thing and uh because of that people say
Hey you know I'm gonna try to reduce my
yeah
my dependence on the dollar and so the
what the United States government is
doing might backfire you know we have to
see how do you foresee countries
becoming more nationalistic as the
I guess as the extinction draws nearer
you know if if you go back to the 1920s
and 30s and even earlier uh people were
very very nationalists everything was
divided by Nation today we're you know
the uh youth right out there they're not
so fanatic about nationalism I don't
think but well I don't know about no
there is there is to some degree but I
mean in general people say look you know
politicians I don't believe in my own
politics and let alone my flag or my
national anthem you don't see
nationalism coming back well not in with
the strength that you had in the world
that led to World War one and two I
don't was it was it a lack of
information because since nowadays we
have the internet and we see people from
all over we're like oh they're human you
can't really do the whole uh
dehumanization thing anymore yeah what
uh Hitler did what Stalin did with all
these uh rulers did you know they
instilled nationalism and they they
themselves grew with national journalism
so they their their own they nurtured
you know uh or were nurtured into
nationalism since they were kids but
today I think nationalism is just
reserved for football games and you know
uh World competitions that's when you
cheer for your uh home country but when
it comes to Wars I don't think there are
people are as fanatic like saying okay
you love your country go fight for it uh
I love my country only when it's
football how do you think that that
works with Russia and Ukraine for
example what do you think the Russian
soldiers think well on the one hand you
have the ukrainians where are they
because they're here yeah because you're
here okay so we gotta let's get them out
of them the Russians they say Hey you
know I had my life I was gonna get
married I have a kid and the government
is sending me to the front and a lot of
people don't like that so I think you're
gonna have more Russians uh complaining
about being sent to the front than
ukrainians who are in this have more
reason to be nationalistic okay so how
that's going to play out I think it's
got a lot to do more with the weapons
that each side gets right than with what
the soldiers think okay that's my take
on that but uh last uh Point here we
have China and uh they're building their
own
Airline uh building uh company which uh
will be competing against Airbus and
Boeing so uh you know the other day we
had um who was it macron who went over
there to China to see if he could sell
some more planes and the Chinese said
well we'll see about that you know and
he went there and he said oh look uh we
we don't like the Americans uh telling
us what to do and the Chinese say yeah
yeah we understand but we're not going
to buy any of your airplanes and maybe
one of the reasons that she and ping
decided not to do
order or to place new orders is because
maybe they're gonna count on their own
airplanes especially in the United
States and their allies including France
uh start limiting the technology that
flows to China but that's what I'm
saying about nationalism I don't mean
like the civilian National I mean the
fact that all these nations are kind of
trying to limit their dependence on
other countries it seems like everyone
every country is seeing the downsides of
that the fact that whoever has the power
can kind of puppet everyone so like oh
[__] we have to be self-sustaining
so that really seems to be we're drawing
each other because
international trade is so uh developed
today compared to what was in the 30s
and 40s even you know up to World War II
today uh international trade is much
much bigger percentage-wise uh and also
importance for every economy in the
world than it was before World War II
and I think that's going to have an
impact
yeah
okay let's move on to a question do you
think uh artificial intelligence could
solve uh Extinction
human extinction I I don't believe that
AI has anything to do with anything uh
you really underestimate it I completely
get rid of AI completely it has no
bearing on anything as far as I'm
concerned you know I don't even take it
into consideration but yeah but you
don't think you're too old to maybe the
power of it I mean you didn't predict
internet either
hey I was in the business of course I
did the power of the internet no I have
very little uh regard for AI why do you
guys
offhand because first of all uh you know
AI is only going to be used for uh you
know uh robots around the house maybe
you know sell some gadgets no one's
going to have any money to buy robots
everybody's gonna have to do their own
thing anyway so AI is dead no but not
robot but
AI is a robot that's what it is
I don't mean like a physical robot I
mean like AI on your computer you mean
like uh what chat like a
superbt right but like to the to the
umpteenth power yeah but I mean
umpteenth power what do we mean by that
a
lot of information and give you the
answer to the question that you asked
yeah one thing is for that uh the other
day someone uh in fact I use that as an
example if I'll uh wanted to know what
uh chant gbt would say uh about
um the word exist oh and uh
the chat screwed up big time so
hopefully we get a new chat that at
least okay I can tell you one thing the
downside to the AI is it can as far as I
can tell and I don't know if there's a
way around that it can only process then
from the the I want to say faulty
information that we have collected as a
species we're feeding it all our answer
is so it it can only make the best
answer out of that but I don't know if
there's some way to program in such a
way that he can even see the faults in
what we've collected I think we make a
too big of a deal about these robots I
keep calling them robots I hate the word
AI I call them robots whether they're on
the Internet or in physical or you know
cleaning jobs or whatever but because uh
you're just offhand yeah I completely
have no faith whatsoever and all that
because uh the AIS the AIS are always
programmed by humans and to say that the
robot is at some point going to replace
the human and take off in this
Singularity that people like Kurzweil
say that at some point they're just
gonna take off and technology is going
to go you know Sky High
for example the famous uh robot that
beat the go player
it's making moves that we couldn't have
made yeah that kind of stuff uh a lot of
that has to do with again
um if you program something it can
develop new moves like chess or whatever
yeah uh that's a little different than
uh making decisions like a human does
with its brain with his brain there's a
difference
that's a long chat let's let's move on
but I'm saying uh I think that'd be a
more interesting yeah
oh yeah okay so space time someone uh I
covered that in the last couple of times
and people had some comments about it so
let's uh let's review some of that
because it leads to the subject matter
today which is weight which has to do
this okay so uh here it is uh in physics
real quick before you start what what if
you typed in rope hypothesis stuff into
the aiss hey this actually is the best
theory then would you be like no that
would be an opinion
I don't know
okay look so this spell says in physics
horrible evacue evacuate uh or planosome
commonly stated as nature of horse a
vacuum okay it came out of uh people
like Aristotle right vacuum energy is an
underlying background so he believes
space right is made out of energy or
filled with energy I don't know what the
difference is there I mean is space the
same thing as energy is space filled
with energy if it's filled with energy
you're saying that space is a container
and I want you to draw this container
for me otherwise you can't say it's a
container that energy fills well is it
just me or did he make a mistake where
he's saying vacuum energy you're saying
whenever there's a vacuum the vacuum
sucks everything in but really what's
happening is the pressure of everything
is is pushing stuff into this no no but
here he says it in the next line energy
that exists in space throughout the
entire universe the sentence doesn't
mean anything it means a lot because
what the fellow is saying is the
universe space whatever vacuum whatever
you want to call it I don't care what
you call it nothing call it nothing
vacuum whatever you want to call that
nothing that black stuff between the
Earth and the moon he's saying it's a
physical object it's a container and
it's filled completely with energy with
vacuum energy yeah but why is he saying
that like I said because people have
this nonsense
I think he got something wrong because
he's saying that whenever there's a
vacuum whenever there's there's nothing
there there's still energy yeah but he's
saying that the energy in the vacuum
whatever the [__] that means is pulling
everything in but really what's
happening but that's not the point we
don't get to pulling yet the guy is
already giving an assumption he's making
an assumption a hypothesis his
assumption is that space is a physical
object it's a container
okay it's a container meaning a
container has sides to it you know means
we don't know what's on the outside of
that that's what something he's got to
tell us right what's on the outside of
the container giving shape to The
Container but he's saying the container
inside every bit of it which he calls
space is filled with his so-called
energy what does that mean meaning that
space and energy are one and the same
okay because he's saying that every bit
of space is filled with energy meaning
space and energy is the same thing me or
you could I don't know if if you can
change that in any way because see when
you have a container and you put gas in
it it doesn't fill every bit of what's
inside the container which is the
nothingness but this though says that
every bit is filled inside with this
whatever thing energy is that means
energy and space are the same thing the
the container itself is energy and all
we need to know is what's on the outside
giving shape to this container okay so
you cannot say the universe is filled
everywhere with energy energy because
you all you did was leave the container
the notion container to God or whatever
you're not explaining what what the
universe is what is the universe is it a
container is it a a box yeah a sphere
what is the you know what's the shape of
the you know where's the shape of space
that's what you got to tell us if you're
going to treat it as a physical object
as a container
and if you say well it's infinite then
it's not a container okay Center
contains a concept because there are no
no object is infinite all objects are
finite you're talking about a concept
okay and so you can't have it both ways
either it's a container with shape or
it's a concept in which case you cannot
say we live inside a concept we live
inside a
um a box that is not a box that is a
love that is uh thought or anything else
basically going to use the concept right
space is nothing right which is a
concept but we don't live within a
concept okay it's not like I go to the
end of space and find a wall there you
know so space is not is a concept
because it's nothing the only thing that
exists are the things the atoms the uh
the uh planets the asteroids the stars
that exists though those are the objects
right but you cannot say we live within
space or with in the universe because
Space Universe vacuum Concepts there the
word is nothing and nothing is that
which doesn't have shape which is the
opposite of a thing which is the
opposite of an object I mean I think
again the problem becomes all the
semantic stuff where it becomes hard
just to talk scientifically unless you
define your terms but not just that but
like if if you it's hard to speak
without metaphor
it's almost impossible but unless you
define your terms even then is is like a
Minefield no no I know it ain't it is I
like to Define terms that way we know
exactly yeah yeah but people get the
real life importance of defining where
they say oh that's word salad oh that's
uh semantic you know what I mean no no I
don't
know and so this uh absolutely
absolutely says that he sees nothing and
I agree with him he sees nothing okay
the vacuum energy is a spheric is a
special case of Zero Point Energy that
relates to the quantum vacuum whatever
you said there I don't know the effects
of vacuum energy can be experimentally
observed so he can observe the vacuum he
can observe nothing and I agree with
there completely with him he observes
nothing okay he can see nothing
okay so uh here we have uh something the
follow in the who allegedly is a
physicist and now he's really in my
opinion just a bozo he's not a scientist
but he's he's in the uh entertainment
business really and some of you seen him
around if I can put them in here we
really gotta ban the word energy don't
we
yeah here's his name is uh Siegel Ethan
Siegel some of you probably know him and
here it is and he's a 70 year old
Quantum prediction comes true as
something is Created from nothing
okay so he says in our common experience
you can't get something for nothing in
our Quantum realm something really can
emerge from nothing and he goes in there
and so it tells you how and how
particles and anti-particles come in
from the void okay so he goes through
that uh rig Monroe telling you that and
then he explains the mechanism he goes
in there and says what's the mechanism
there's nothing no and then there's
nothing here's the mechanism let's
imagine we got very very strong electric
field that's a nothing I guess right so
we're going to start with an electric
field he's going to call that nothing
stronger than anything we would ever
hope to make on earth a Quantum vacuum
in this region of space is going to be
extremely strongly polarized with a
Quantum vacuum the vacuum is polarized
yeah he's saying that uh this field is
nothing it's a Quantum vacuum but it's
polarized so again they contradict
themselves and it's all word salad it's
all semantics that these people get
tangled you know in in their own
semantics strong polarization means
strong separation between positive and
negative charges how those came out to
be I don't know I thought we said
there's nothing there okay we're talking
about the charges are there but yeah but
not the back it's the vacuum nothing is
there but we have char charges whatever
charges are whatever field is you know
we have so let's just throwing words out
yeah if you're an electric fuel in a
region of space is strong enough blah
blah
blah and so he goes in and says that's
what the schwinder effect is
unsurprisingly it's never been observed
in a laboratory no kidding yeah
polarization of nothing so it's like
this other fellow who's you know trying
to see nothing you know so I don't know
how uh how these people really try to
make sense of this when they're saying
look uh we have this vacuum this this is
their argument they said we have vacuum
okay and in that vacuum we have Fields
okay what do you mean you have a field
what is a field is it a something or
nothing
and so yeah they treat it as a concept
but they're also treating as an object
because it says the vacuum has Fields
whatever Fields is and then they say
there's charges in there what do you
mean charges suddenly we have feelings
we have Santa Clauses
but there's nothing there
and then we created something out of
nothing what do you mean I don't know I
thought you said you had field you had
charges you had Santa Claus in there oh
it works what's so that's how they do
their their magic that's how they create
something from Nothing by beginning with
something okay and um so here we have
another felon he says you cannot measure
the length contraction inside the moving
reference frame because any ruler or
tape you use to measure the is also
subjected to length contraction which I
talked the other day about you know we
were talking about special relativity
and I didn't mention the proper length
and the proper length the proper Mass
the proper time what does that mean me
and I guess this guy didn't understand
that means that whatever whatever's
traveling with you you measure normally
it's the guy out there you know the guy
in Cambridge and the fellow over there
in uh Harvard those are the ones that
are measuring your time your mass your
length at a different rate or different
value okay but not you you and your
frame of reference your proper time is
normal so you know the guy didn't
clarify anything I guess he just didn't
understand what proper length proper
time proper mass is and
um and then we have this and again all
related to the space time and special
relativity how all this relates to that
right and here we have another phone
that says um I'm sorry this is um
um well yeah so space time is another
name for The Ether here we go again but
somehow space-time waves with gravity
and yeah he's not the first guy to say
this okay he he's saying something which
is correct which comes out of um Nobel
Prize winner here in Laughlin and he
said the following the modern concept of
the vacuum of space which is what all
these people say they has nothing in it
but then has something right confirmed
every day by experiment is a
relativistic ether but we do not call it
this because it is taboo
okay and that's a Nobel Prize to any of
those words mean well the point here is
that you know
um
the foes saying you know space them is
an ether and that's confirmed here by
this mathematical physicist Nobel Prize
winner okay he's saying the same thing
yeah it's this it's uh it's just saying
space time is the soup of particles no
what everybody
talks into you know um double space
because they they go in there on the one
hand they say vacuum what is vacuum well
vacuum is space so what is space well
it's nothing
[Music]
how did you prove it well because we
went in there we separated particles
that appear from the void what do you
mean they appear from the void they
appear from the void they were there in
the void
you know you can't say the void was
nothing because the particles were there
and the question is did you rip a piece
of nothing is that the particle a piece
of nothing or was the particle there
they don't know no but it's not the
question they don't know you cannot
conceptualize well that's true that too
that's what I mean is they see things
happening and then they're like oh what
must have happened is ABC it's the
explanation that's irrational
the explanation is irrational you cannot
say that particles appear from nothing
okay because if they appear from nothing
means the particle was making up nothing
well that's and how do you how do you
and and how do you explain that unless
the particles are cubic then you can say
okay uh you know they're neck to neck
side to side with the vacuum is made of
these particles right and what happens
when you pull a particle out you leave a
hole in nothing I mean what are we
talking about here you know so you have
to conceptualize it they can't
conceptualize it yeah they just say oh
particles
when you get down to Brass tags at some
point you have to explain some missing
hole that's being left behind yeah I
mean when the particle comes in from the
vacuum what did you what did it leave
behind a hole in the vacuum or holding
nothing
I mean we already had nothing now we
have a hole in nothing which is more or
less what a black hole is nothing
okay and that leads us to the issue of
um weight and we're going to start with
this uh warp time issue here okay and
this is what uh because people say uh
Bill you're you're making fun of special
relativity and uh general relativity You
Are by explaining it well yeah but I'm
just saying what these people say this
is this is the explanation of why the
Earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system
visiting a bad time this is the physical
mechanism that they propose they say
that the Earth doesn't fly out of the
solar system because time is Warped and
people say well that's not what they say
here you see it it's in front of your
eyes they're saying look uh Earth is
encountering a wall a warp time and
that's what prevents the Earth from
flying out of the solar system and yeah
and and what they say this is a metaphor
it's a figure of speech you're not
supposed to take it literally okay if
it's not tell me what is
okay don't say that I got it wrong you
can't conceive of it is tell me tell me
what is the mechanism that relativity
special relativity of general relativity
quantum mechanics String Theory I don't
care tell me the mechanism mathematical
physics proposes for why the Earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system I
want a mechanism okay
right don't tell me that uh time has
worked and and then say well I didn't
really mean that you don't not supposed
to take it literally no no if you're
just gonna say time is Warped I'm gonna
take it literally whatever you tell me
I'm gonna take it literally so uh
general relativity at least right says
that time is warm and it means exactly
that literally time is Warped because
now you saw it here let me show it to
you again this is warp time this is what
it looks like this is the mechanism that
they proposed okay so the Earth doesn't
fly out of the solar system because time
it makes no sense on so many levels
right does time not happen above the net
is time only on that well I mean yeah
like you said this time you can take
that to any level there's so many things
wrong with it my point my point is that
is the physical interpretation that
relativity proposes for why the Earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system
you're gonna say that's an analogy or
you're not supposed to take it literally
no that is the mechanism if you don't
believe that tell me what the mechanism
is that general relativity proposes for
why the Earth doesn't fly out of the
solar system don't tell me I'm wrong
tell me what is yes it's a simple
question very simple and until you can
tell me that that is the mechanism warp
time they're treating time is a physical
object and they're curbing it and
they're saying this wall of time comes
up against the skin of the earth and
that's why the Earth doesn't fly out
it's the roulette mechanism I feel the
wall of time whenever I wake up early in
the morning it doesn't squash
okay so so the issue is that time you
know this the time warpage and and
treating time as a physical object came
out of special relativity okay and
because of that they applied it to mass
okay and they applied it to also to
length Okay like we saw a minute ago
okay so what is it here um
here we have uh this situation where a
fellow says no it doesn't gain atoms
meaning you know when uh Mass uh travels
at the close to the speed of light uh in
special relativity and I said well the
reason uh special relativity uh or the
explanation they give is that at high
speeds right the the things gain gain
weight mass or weight well that's the
point the point is I'm saying it's one
of the two it either gains weight or
gains Mass if it gains Mass if that's
what special relativity says it's
acquiring more atoms okay because that's
what mass is it's defined as quantity of
matter okay if if instead it presses on
the scale harder harder because it's
probably faster and faster and faster
you have an acceleration against the
scale right then we're talking about
weight and not about
um Mass so when they say Mass increase
this is what they're saying is it's
gaining more matter that's what they're
saying that's the thing they don't use
their words no but I'm getting to that
and here you can see when the mass
increase the mass of each atom is
increased this guy says the mass of each
atom each atom so that's that's an
incorrect way no but but then are they
saying that the atoms get fatter get
fatter better more
but this is what this uh fellow says
okay but then he says he contradicts
himself he says the weight effect
at motion you mentioned is not related
to the velocity but acceleration
in other words it speeds up which is
what I said the other day but he didn't
catch that I didn't say it relate to
Velocity it's acceleration just like uh
gravitational acceleration but he says
um
special relativity theory is all about
close to light speed and or super
massive scale in other words he he's
saying he's saying that the thing is
trap he's saying two things on the one's
hand he's saying the atoms get fatter
and the other one he says it's traveling
at bigger it's accelerating yeah so he's
not he's not telling us why'd you put
baits on there no that's not bad that's
uh that's uh what's his name uh Newton
he's laughing at him
no but he's uh he's outraged by what
this guy's saying you know okay so
here's the fat atom theory you know
where is the fat atom yeah that's what
it is okay so here we have
um uh this oh come on you need a better
system
it just keeps falling on the other side
sometimes okay so the southern file says
Mass just as in Newtonian physics refers
to inertial mass the ability to resist
acceleration no no that's not mass
that's called weight okay so uh he says
the fact that you interpret it as
acquiring more atom is just a beating a
straw man you you aren't impressing
anyone mass is definitely not the amount
of substance okay that's what he's
saying okay listen to what he's saying
you say this so I'll agree on that no
he's uh he agrees that he's the only
person on the planet that agrees on land
that it's not the amount of substance I
thought we agree with that too no no it
is mass is the amount oh Mass sorry okay
yeah
foreign
Mass refers to the ability of an object
to resist acceleration and he puts the
equation there I didn't put that there
okay he put it there he says Mass equals
mass times acceleration F or Force I'm
sorry Force equals mass times
acceleration and essentially he's saying
mass is is equal to mass times
acceleration because he's saying that
that's what mass is mass times
acceleration okay so he's contradicting
himself because he's putting his name
mess is equal to mass times acceleration
uh he's treating mass as a force and
he's saying it's it's got to do with
acceleration that's what weight is not
what mass is again and these people are
cheating and I'm going to show that more
in a second okay so please bear with me
I want to make sure we destroy this
notion that mass is not the quantity of
matter okay so let's find out what mass
is here we have the Wikipedia and the
dictionary to Independent sources and
they put them under physics in both
cases math is not physics but the force
acting on an object due to the
acceleration of or gravity which is
weight that's the definition of weight
right
the force that gravitation exerts upon a
body equal to the mass of the body times
the local acceleration of gravity okay a
measure of mass that's what uh
weight is it's a force okay or at least
this is what they we're going to
challenge that as well it's not a force
but that's what math says math viz yay
mathematical physics says weight is a
force which is equal to mass times
acceleration so these people when they
say look it's the uh inertia the ability
to resist change they're talking about
wait they're not talking about mass mass
is the quantity of matter as we will see
in a second here so let's first show
this let's prove the definition of
weight and mass okay here's uh
a distinction between uh weight and mass
here we have NASA okay it says what is
weight and it says weight is a force
right Force equals mass times
acceleration right caused by the
gravitational attraction of the earth
and here's the equation of weight okay
uh Theory oh sorry uh that's what I
wanted to
okay this is the weight equation says
Force equals gravitation uh
gravitational constant Mass 1 times mass
two divided by distance squared and
eventually they end up with weight
equals what mass times acceleration of
gravity the little G is that what uh you
know gravitational acceleration so that
is weight which is according to
mathematical physics a force okay so
again what you have to look at is that
these are the definitions that
mathematical physics has out there okay
you cannot say later on that you're
going to change all this and um you know
and uh give your own definition like
these people are doing these people are
saying well no that's not what it is in
relativity no masses mass and weight is
weight you can give your own definition
yeah but then you got to continue you
gotta you cannot say that for this I'm
going to use this notion of mass for
that I'm going to use the notion another
notion of mass because then you're using
word salad you're doing you know
semantics okay uh they always accuse me
of doing some math oh he's got
semantical arguments well now you're
doing semantics if you're going to
change the definitions on us Mass
quantity of matter weight mass times
acceleration in other words the
something pushing up against a scale
yeah inertia that's right that's uh uh
weight that's not mass okay inertia is
not mass and let's make sure we
understand that here uh see what this
says uh fellow says the theory of
relativity has been proved see they
always prove all these things right
correct in the past by equipping
synchronized atomic clocks to two
different satellites okay furthermore
modern GPS in order to work takes time
dilation into consideration we are
absolutely sure that the flow of time is
relative and its flow is not a constant
there are no doubts about it again what
these people are talking about always is
that special relativity for time
dilation weight uh Mass increase uh and
length contraction have been proven okay
they always talk about proof about truth
they say we know it's a fact okay and so
you can't even talk to these people
because you know they already proven
everything okay
um
by getting back to mass here uh we have
um definition of mass okay says uh
Museum of Natural History says mass and
weight may seem to be the same thing but
in fact these two measurements are very
different what is mass mass is the total
amount of matter or stuff in an object
very clear weight is the force of
gravity on an object okay Mass always
stays the same but weight can change
depending on how much gravity is acting
upon an object it just says it pretty
concisely yeah I think it's it's clear
right and here we have
um I think we got it folks you're going
crazy on this guy yeah I hear we though
Wikipedia says something similar okay it
says a in scientific content masses the
amount of matter right in an object
weight is the force exerted on an object
matter by gravity so I don't know what
all these people don't understand when
the definitions are out there and they
say well no masses uh What uh Einstein
said for special relativity which is
that mass is the amount of inertia okay
and here we have some people who say
that and these people again you know you
wonder about them uh here's uh one way
they always prove to you okay that mass
is always the same but what changes is
weight and I think everybody learned
this in high school okay or thereabouts
you take the one kilogram right and you
take it to the moon does it weigh one
kilogram and they say well the mass
remained the same but what changes the
weight standard uh you know high school
stuff and you say why did the weight
change well because the gravitational
attraction changed on the moon there's
less gravity on the moon why did the
mass stay the same because the number of
atoms the quantity of matter is the same
okay so we got that uh Mass never
changes because it's the quantity of
atoms quantity of atoms we count we
count how many atoms uh ma weight we
measure measuring and Counting are two
different
um things what about the fatness of the
atoms have we put this into
consideration well the fact is of the
atom let's assume that I mean what are
we saying that how did it acquire more
how did it become bigger the atom
acquire more matter right because I mean
I don't know you're gonna explain it so
whatever little bits of matter came into
and that's how the atom became fatter uh
you can't escape Mass being the quantity
of matter anyone who changes that
definition is lying is simply trying to
get his theory through at all costs
trying to win an argument that's all and
that's what the special relativist did
they simply wanted to win an argument
that's it nothing more than that because
they had to change the definition in
order to tell you that Mass
changed when everybody says Mass cannot
change because you count Mass how many
marbles are in the bag there's ten
there's always ten unless you had more
marbles than the 12th Marvel will come
from yeah like right that's it you got
to put more marbles if you want to have
more mass inside the bag
if if the bag travels and and you know
goes faster and faster there's
acceleration and presses down on the
scale
stronger and stronger as time goes by
then it can act as if there were 12
marbles right and and what is the scale
doing that's the inertia that's the
inertia part of weight okay so don't
tell me that that's got any either one
of those has anything to do with mass
mass of the quantity of matter never
changes okay and so for people to say
well I know we have another definition
of mass and yeah and uh
um here we have it
um in fact someone tells you why they
came up with this Mass changing and
special relativity and this is uh from
the University of Virginia so this is
their explanation okay
so speed yeah Mass really does increase
with speed but then he goes in there
with a caveat he says actually there is
continuing debate among physicists
meaning mathematical physics and they're
mathematicians have nothing to do with
physics concerning this concept of
relativistic mass relativistic yeah it
says the debate is largely what semantic
yeah and here you can see why it's
semantic okay
give me a second here it's just a bunch
of miscommunications no no no no here it
is look
here's a Wikipedia shows you why it's
semantic in physical science meaning in
the religion of mathematics right one
may distinguish conceptually between at
least seven different aspects of mass or
seven physical Notions that involve the
concept Mass okay you can see where the
problem starts yeah if you have 10
different definitions for mass or
Notions then yeah we're all going to run
into trouble okay and then people wonder
why you're so anal retentive Yeah by
definition and language and here's a uh
what John Wheeler and Edwin Taylor said
in their books space-time physics says
nature does not offer us any concept as
the amount of matter history has struck
down every proposal to Define such a
turn even if we could count number of
atoms or by any other counting method
try to evaluate amount of matter that
number would not equal Mass what does he
mean by that number would not equal Mass
well the the issue here again is that
all these people cannot Define mass they
cannot Define hold on hold on but that
last line is
I thought that is Mass
why would that not be a sufficient
because they need to change it to
explain space-time physics which is the
name of their book they cannot talk
about space-time if if mass is the
quantity of matter that's the whole
issue so they had to cheat they had they
had to put in that's why he put that
that last line is a lie to fit his stuff
in right and that's what even if you
could count them uh there's some magic
there yeah they have to
they have to stop defining the word mass
yes
if they Define the word mass uh very
stringently very strictly yeah
not not uh you know with ten different
definitions seven definitions if they
have only one definition for mass
they're dead they're dead because either
it's quantity of matter or it's inertia
or or weight and what these people they
want to put the weight in there but when
they need it yeah yeah that's the
problem that's the whole problem it's a
semantic issue like this guy said okay
and so here that's so crazy says uh so
how can this Mass increase be understood
yeah how can it be understood it depends
on what we're what the question was no
depending on how you define the words
you know every form of energy possesses
inertia huh what's this got to do with
mass the kinetic energy itself has
inertia okay and it says inertia is a
defining property of mass okay let's
find out what this inertia nonsense is
okay it says inertia is the idea that an
object will continue its current motion
until some force causes its speed or
direction to change okay so again we're
talking about resistance that's what
inertia essentially comes down to and we
have Don Lincoln over there at the Fermi
lab and he says at low speeds inertia
equals mass at high speeds inertia does
not equal Mass so these people are
playing around with words that's all
they're doing it says there the debate
is largely about semantic okay Nazi
semantics and it says the increase in
kinetic energy e over the one second
period is just the work done by the
force okay so they're talking about
again Force equals mass times
acceleration they're not talking about
Mass okay
that's the whole issue and here you have
what what it is here's a picture of that
we have the little atom it's pressing
down harder against the scale because
it's accelerating that's what's called
inertia inertia has to do with weight
and not with mass Force according to
mathematical physics is equal to mass
times acceleration what they've done is
they've replaced the word force with
mass and they replace the word mass with
inertia essentially you know they're
saying well we're not really talking
about math we're talking about inertia
at high speeds mass is not equal to
inertia
okay so so all they did was play around
with words throughout well one problem
that definitely comes along with mass is
what one of our personal people here
pointed out that even if you could count
an atom a hydrogen atom isn't the same
as Uranian atom and they have different
masses yeah but that's why in what I
mean is it's hard to quantify in that
sense it ain't uh like I say in my book
the unit of mass is the hydrogen atom
what is a uranium atom it's 92 hydrogen
atoms that's all they are so so we use
the unit of mass always as the hydrogen
atom why because from every hydrogen
atom we have a single rope connected to
every atom in the universe what does
that mean for Uranium uranium has 92
atoms right uh hydrogen atoms there's 92
ropes one for each one of those atoms
connected to every atom in the universe
it's very simple okay to understand it's
a conceptually straightforward okay
determine because how do you count the
hydrogen atoms it's an assumption it's
all these are assumptions okay you have
to begin with an assumption in order to
explain your theories that's the
Assumption the assumption is every
hydrogen atom is a unit of mass everyone
has a single
rope connected to any other hydrogen
atom in the universe straightforward if
one atom uh is big like uh Valium fat
atom we have 92 hydrogen atoms stuck in
there compressed by what by the sun
that's how we made it uh Star right okay
so where does this take us well what we
we do in science is we try to define the
words especially try to figure out the
difference between force and tension
weight is not a force as mathematical
physics has held since the days of new
oh yeah go slow with this one right yeah
yeah so so let's wait it's not a force
yeah let's let's put our Universal movie
uh thing here what is the universal
movie it's a snapshot of uh everything
in the universe at a given location like
if we froze the universe right you take
a snapshot
now everything moves whatever's tiny
amount moves to the next location you
take another snapshot and you everything
moves to another location take another
snapshot so we have the movie of all
these snapshots in a snapshot all you
see is what exists all that the atoms in
the universe where they are Etc you know
there's no motion there's no motion okay
and so anything that's in a single frame
of this movie is static it only
represents static Concepts and here we
have them okay object distance location
and existence in a single frame of the
universal movement and you use this as a
tool to to separate that which exists
and that which doesn't uh essentially
but not only that it defines certain
Concepts that can only fit in a single
frame in other words that are static
Concepts versus Dynamic Concepts which
require at least two frames or more of
the universal movie and that's why we
separate these static single frame
Concepts from from Dynamic Concepts
which require at least two frames that's
the notion okay people have a hard time
understanding uh the difference between
static and dynamic Concepts that's what
this tool is used for motion requires
two frames of the movie you cannot have
Motion in a single frame of the movie
you know the Mona Lisa doesn't smile in
a single frame if you want her to smile
you need to see at these two frames of
Mona Lisa okay uh smile is a verb okay
you're saying she's not smiling she's
not smiling no oh [__] yeah it's blowing
my line on too many loans now okay Mona
Lisa is not smiling okay but here's the
issue the issue is you have all these
static Concepts object distance location
existence all are static Concepts you do
not need to move in order to exist
you can't move if you have location if
you move uh you have motion not location
let me just bring back the original
thing the reason you brought this up was
because you're trying to explain
um differentiate or separate static
Concepts from Dynamic Concepts love is a
dynamic concept you cannot put love in a
single frame of the universal movement
no not earlier than that well the reason
you brought this up is because you're
talking about tension versus four yeah
here it is and I've got them there so we
have tension is a static concept and the
mathematicians have turned it into
Dynamic concept because they say tension
is a type of force and the way they
explain it and here's a graphic version
of it so that you can see how
mathematical physics has screwed this
one up completely here we have it they
say tension on the right side there is a
string that's being
pulled from two sides it's pulled by the
box which is being pulled by whatever
gravity is downwards and at the same
time it's pulled by the roof or the
ceiling or whatever where the string is
tied so what they say is you need two
forces two Dynamic Concepts to produce
tension two counterbalanced yeah but
tension is a static concept because
there is no motion once something is
completely tense
and this is where the problem is because
they've defined tension as two forces in
opposite direction two motions whereas
we define tension is a static concept
because nothing moves it finally reached
a
um uh equilibrium where nothing moves in
the string the string is stretched to
maximum okay so tension is not a force
and that's uh the first issue that we
want to put through and so we're going
to replace the word Force
in mass mass divided by this and squared
in Newton's equation we're going to omit
the G there the gravitational constant
weight equal to mass mass distance
squared is not a force it's a tension
okay that's what we're going to argue
here okay tension is not a force why
because force and influence that causes
the emotion the motion there is no
motion intention but there is motion
hopefully in force someone wins the tug
of war okay of an object tension
acceleration is zero the system is in
equilibrium a system is in equilibrium
when the sum of all forces is zero so uh
that's a definition that comes out of
um uh the Wikipedia but the point here
is that if it's in equilibrium it
becomes a static concept I would say the
the difficult part to understand this is
you don't you don't make force an object
as most people do because force in the
mind of people like when you have the
the pendulum what's it called the
Newton's Cradle right yeah once when
someone says when a little kid asks you
know how did what how did the first ball
cause the the last one to fly off yeah
normally would say oh the forest
traveled through these and hit it away
yeah the energy the energy your field
you're not making you're not making
you're not making that step you're not
saying there's a you're not objectifying
energy or Force
and and that's the part that's hard to
understand yeah because people turn
everything into physical yeah the energy
is a physical object that's why force is
a physical objective I have a buddy
who's an engineer and he also talks
about forces and but he talks about
forces uh
with tension like he'll say the force
goes through here and here yeah and it's
like yeah but there is no nothing
traveling no no but there's only winning
the tug of war yeah but the issue they
use the word Force yeah but they use it
as a physical object in a physical
interpretation that's a No-No when I'm
done I'm pressing my hands together they
say oh there's two forces they're going
towards each other and you would say no
no because force it cannot go through
anything force is a concept you gotta
say four says this and force is that
that's the hard part what you got to
tell me is what physical object does
this causes the force and that's where
people never get into they say the force
does it when when a billiard ball hits
into another one someone will say okay
where did the energy go yeah where did
the motion go and you're like there's no
such thing as something as emotion going
somewhere right those things energy
going anywhere energy force field those
are not physical object you cannot use
those in physics but that's really hard
those words has been brainwashed in high
school but it's not just brainwashed in
high school because it because as we see
it it feels like a physical object when
you see a ball roll at one hit one and
then this one goes on this one stops
you're like oh something got transferred
it just looks like that an object is not
that which you can see yeah or touch I
know and objects that which I [__] okay
[__] I'm the uh yeah you're like
but it's it's hard to wrap your head
around that part okay so when you say a
force is only when a tug of war is won
that is a thing that most people would
have trouble with yeah because people
would say even if the even if no one's
winning the type of War there's forces
there's there's there's strengths at
combat there yeah but strength requires
an object otherwise you're doing black
magic you're introducing Spirit yeah but
that's what that's how they speak of it
when they say no there's a lot of forces
not to treat these words
but but like if you ask anyone they'd be
like okay there's a lot of forces in
this room that we're not aware of
because like for example there's a
million forces I'm just talking about uh
uh not physical I'm not speaking
scientifically right now I'm speaking in
normal talk there's a lot of forces in
this building you said it that's that's
the key issue a normal normal speak
common speak uh in fact I'm sure uh
Architects even speak like this when the
building is is being constructed they
have to calculate where all the forces
go yeah
winning the thing or else the building
would fall apart obviously but that's
why we need to do semantics word salad
we have to do what does the word force
mean look up the definition and it says
something about motion and a verb motion
is a verb so you cannot say the verb did
this the motion the motion is moving
right that's what you're saying so you
cannot use the word force in science the
word force is outlawed but then energy
is out but then it becomes but it
becomes hard to speak without that's
what I was telling you when it becomes
hard to speak without a metaphor because
even if you define it you still have to
use words to talk about the forces going
through the building that's why you have
to identify the physical objects that
are invisible intangible that which we
can see or touch is not an object that
which has shape is an object so you have
to tell you have to draw the object that
you're proposing you cannot say the
force does this the field is that the
energies does this that's irrational
yeah yeah time does this time doesn't do
anything it's hard not to objectify
energy
but the basic example is the two
billiard balls hitting each other
there's the same amount of matter oh
sorry Mass there's no masses being being
added or gained or transferred right
it's just uh motion of one hitting the
other and then the motion being
transferred but obviously since motion
isn't a physical object it can't be
transferred right but something is
moving or something's happening that
means we don't understand what causes
Newton's uh cradle until you identify
all the invisible stuff in the room but
it's not even invisible it's just not
there well no because there's something
happening no because if you explain it
saying that what was transferred was the
force what was transferred was the
energy you didn't explain anything you
haven't explained it yeah okay I'll
grant you that but how do you speak in
terms when you have an object we always
have we can all agree there's no object
yeah that we have a ball and you have
another Ball but the third thing that we
turn into an object that isn't an object
the energy that's for the next class
it's such a simple
not happening but this is it's like it's
like a spirit okay so let's end this
with this here is the our solution to
this uh what is mass times mass divided
by distance Square well mass mass
divided by distance square is the number
of ropes that interconnect and uh two
objects at a given distance and we're
isolating the all these these two
objects here from all other objects in
the universe which is not completely
true it's just so that we understand the
concept so what is an effective rope
well we say that if you have uh atoms
one two three four and five of the cube
there
on the same
um a line and the same axis as number
six
that is uh an atom of the um cylinder
okay you have only one effective row
it's like number one is pulling on
number six and that's it two three four
and five are irrelevant you can prove
this to yourself with a rubber band okay
you just take a rubber band and three
fingers and in fact we can do it here
let me show you here
give me a second here
maybe we can do it here no oh
experiments I thought we'd all do these
well this is not an experiment this is
just uh this is not an experiment okay
because people say oh Phil you did an
experiment you did on Sunday this is not
an experiment what we're doing here is
we're going to show you something so
that you understand the concept okay you
need a new rubber band well no but this
is the point the point is if if you just
hold on to this okay
a third person right hold on to this all
you have is the tug of war between my
hand and his hand I this I don't feel at
all any tug you want to feel a tug you
got to pull it out of alignment now you
feel tell you what down so they can see
it okay well pull it all over you pull
it towards them they won't see you okay
so this is so nice I feel the tug here I
can't feel it right okay so you want to
see how Mass appears and disappears
there you have it Mass appears Mass
disappears oh don't say it like that
that's confusing
the illusion of mess well you you feel a
different Force there's something else
in there that suddenly you don't feel it
when they're on the same axis you do
feel it when they're
okay and that's what we're showing here
okay again no experiments that wasn't an
experiment okay for those who that the
purpose of that was a demonstration just
to show you the concept okay and so what
we're saying is if all atoms are aligned
you only have tug of war between number
six and one if you want to have feel
Adams two three four and five you got to
move the cylinder closer to the cube and
then you can see the ropes go out of
alignment they're not on the same axis
now you feel atoms two three four and
five what has changed what has changed
is a number of effective ropes okay and
that's what gravitational attraction is
the acceleration of gravity and there
you see it on the upper left right uh
two atoms or two thing two objects there
a cylinder in a box they're very far
away from each other all the ropes uh
are almost on the same axis so the
gravity is very very week as the
cylinder and the box of the cube there
approach each other you can see what's
happening to the ropes they fan out and
very close together they fan out even
more so we have more and more effective
ropes that is the acceleration of
gravity that's what Mass 1 Mass 2 over
distance Square represents it's the
number of ropes that interconnect uh the
atoms of these two objects okay so it
has nothing to do with really with
um what these people say which is
inertia I mean I would go I still think
you're you're not giving it full credit
because I don't think it's just
effective ropes when the ropes are
superposed on top of each other I think
it's the aggregate of the angles like
well it's the same thing it's the same
thing it's the same thing because you're
making a binary they're either on top of
each other they're not but this is
different than that also yeah but the
gradient the point here is the phone you
have uh the Earth and the Sun they're
very far away from each other if you
take the Earth and take it all the way
to Alpha Centauri you know for
0.3 light years away a lot of those will
overlap they'll overlap more and more
and more all those atoms so the gravity
will be very very weak but but you get
but as soon as the Earth come closer and
closer to the Sun those same rows will
tend to separate rate be not be on the
same axis and now you're going to feel
gravitational attraction imagine if the
Earth were close to where uh Mercury is
well you can see why Mercury is being uh
world around so so differently you know
why the um perihelion shifts so much
because take a little bead you know move
it around your finger and you'll find
out it goes in all directions now you
take that string you know make it long
and put a bowling ball and just twirl it
around and it'll be very smooth and
that's what's happening in our solar
system that's the reason uh for the
perihelion shift of mercury you know
you're just uh the the sun is twirling
around a little bead very close to it
and you know the um all the ropes are
you know not on the same axis and when
you have a long string like you know uh
I don't know a bowling ball far away
from you and you swing it around well
then now all the even if you had every
atom tied to your hand it's far away you
know they're almost all on the same axis
that's the difference between the Earth
for example and the weird motion of
Mercury
okay uh I think we beat this one to
death obviously there's a lot of
questions on this issue okay so uh all
we can do is present in general terms
what we're talking about here so that
people get the general Notions okay let
me let's move on to our science critic
uh this one I had to present I'm not
gonna leave him behind and uh this is
what he had to say he says that you can
predict
listen to this carefully You can predict
that the Earth is round
You can predict
that the Earth spins and you can predict
that either the earth goes around the
Sun or the sun around the earth he says
you can predict they love the word
prediction because prediction gives them
this thing that the astrologers love so
much that they know they know because
they can predict what's going to happen
in the future and these people predict
that the Earth is spherical and that it
spins yeah that's that's the way they
use it I know that's the that's the
point and here it goes let me show you
what this poor fellow has to say here it
is give me a second here goes
the questions and issues to be addressed
in Nursery battle include
this fellow believes that you can
predict whether the Earth is or isn't
spinning
this follow believes that you can
predict whether the Earth is spherical
and this fellow believes that
predictions lead you to the truth
Bob thinks that the Earth is not
spinning now Bob knows that there are
these extremely sensitive gyroscopes
that have turned even so subtly it's
going to register it now Bob concludes
that if he can get one of these
gyroscopes and it registers no rotation
then the Earth is not spinning
however if it registers a rotation of 15
degrees per hour then the Earth is
obviously spinning this is how you
verify things like the Earth being a
globe or the earth going around the Sun
if we didn't use predictions to validate
certain ideas then we would still
believe that Earth is at the center of
the universe and that the Sun goes
around us
the good thing is that we can test these
ideas to work out what might be true
okay so this all says that you can
predict
that the Earth is spherical You can
predict that the Earth spins and you can
predict that the earth goes around the
sun does that make any sense using the
word prediction predict in that context
can you predict the that the Earth is a
sphere does that make any sense you
could predict it's going to continue to
be so the guys well what the guy is
doing is working in Reverse he doesn't
even know it he doesn't understand what
he's doing here he's trying to explain
why he thinks the Earth is a sphere and
he says look if if I can show through
this experiment something that shows
retroactively you know that the Earth
had to be a sphere because otherwise
that would that result would not happen
that's what he's saying so he's trying
to explain why
why he believes
that the Earth is a sphere a flat
earther where is it show me
flat earther might have an explanation
of why the Earth is flat and he's going
to give you his explanation
is prediction
oh that's that's just the wrong way of
using prediction I know but this is what
these people have the mathematicians
have fed the this prediction nonsense
into the minds of people saying oh we
can predict now why because if they can
predict means that they know how else
would they be able to predict unless
they know so they become these
astrologers or you can say that
astrology is what they inherited and
they say Hey you know this is good
because the astrologers were these guys
that were next to the king and they
could predict whether the King was going
to win or lose in war and so the Kings
loved them gave them a lot of money and
all the girls and whatever you know so
the guy was famous and so these people
want to be famous too and they say oh we
can predict oh how can you predict see
with our mathematics what do you predict
we can predict that the Earth is a
sphere and we can predict that the Earth
spins and we can predict that the
dinosaurs died no even worse they can
predict the past yeah that's what I just
said yeah do you predict that dinosaurs
died no no they predict uh they produce
something even better they predict the
initial conditions of the universe they
can be predicted it yeah they predicted
the initial conditions I want them to
predict the day I was born
it was the same day as the conception of
the Universe I think okay folks I'm out
of breath I'm out of uh I'm not gonna go
through the uh some of the mail that I
don't think there are any a lot of
questions I'll have to go with the
questions next time I need a break here